you actually worked Bonnaroo right
didn't you volunteer I did I've always
had actually the first time I went slept
in my car I'd spent I'd spit I was
working at a tanning bed one personal
plan and like a freshly but he'll Napa
yeah you know I think Radiohead was
playing was the first year radio hit
play and I was working at a tanning bed
because I didn't have a car so I had to
draw I had to walk through the closes
Colossus and so I spent my paycheck on a
Bonnaroo ticket to go see radio and I
was and I slept in my car and it was
that was terrible so the year that jay-z
and Stevie Wonder played God that was my
favorite year of Bonnaroo history yeah I
couldn't afford a ticket and you know
the whole the whole thing that they
dangle is like hey you can work security
yeah we'll pay you like minimum wage but
guess what you do a 12-hour shift and
did you get 12 hours off not an amazing
that twelve hours off is pretty good
sure but but when I got Sun poisoning
Thursday on my leg I was like this is
awful so what it's funny does like so
the first night I was so tired of can't
go see but Stevie Wonder and jay-z were
playing and I was like I was like all
right I'm gonna go me I gotta go see
that so just do you wonder he gets off
jay-z's about to go on I'm trying to get
close and I feel something warm running
down my back and I turn around and there
was a giant man who was on some sort of
drugs hang on oh my god I'm not kidding
I'm not kidding
and I turn around and I just I was like
what's going on right now
but wait what is my life come to and
there turn back around and the guys
already like shot out and I was asked
you know what I've got some toys and
this is awful I'm gonna watch Jamie with
P on my back and that's what I did
the delicate touch of Paul Janeway when
a man is peeing on him he turns around
he says hey so what's going on here what
was your post what did you actually have
to do at Bonnaroo it was your job I was
there there was like a VIP
with a VIP like I was at the door or at
the gate or gate and it was right and so
things I had to do you know check
credentials and then also also make sure
that hippies did not stay in the road
because there's trucks going you know 40
miles an hour by there people just like
man just I'm like you're gonna die
that's right around the same year the
guy got hit by the porta potti cleanup
truck wasn't it that's my point
and so and so what was so magical for me
I even get like kind of emotional
thinking about it because doing that and
Bonnaroo being so close to Birmingham
and me you know what I mean like
spending all my money on a Bonnaroo
ticket and then in 2014
getting to play it it was honestly like
I there are a few points in my life or
professionally and in this that I
vividly remember and that's one of them
because it was just it felt like a dream
it felt like I can't I remember being a
patron and sitting and going I think I
sing better than they do then having a
moment and then being on stage I just
tried to soak it in
[Applause]
a jury to the stories that define the
artists plane who are they what are they
what will you see the what which bands
this year that matter David Brad Steiner
and Barry corner